foreign
's YouTube channel in today's video we
are going to be talking about content
writing now we'll talk about why it is
important how do you write good content
what are the different types of content
that you can write for and for the
different types of media that you want
to use and I'm going to share with you
some really good content writing tools I
am our campman I'm your digital
navigator for this video but before we
start if you like this video click the
like button and if you want to join our
subscribers click the Subscribe button
and click on the notifications Button as
well so you will get automatic
notifications when we come up with new
query new videos so you're ready let's
get started let me give you some
interesting statistics about content and
about content marketing of which content
writing is an important part did you
know that the content marketing industry
is worth more than 400 billion dollars
which is going to grow to close to 900
billion dollars in the next five years
46 of businesses plan to increase their
spent in content creation
content marketing costs 62 percent less
than traditional outbound marketing
methods and it generates three times
more leads
so quite impressive numbers yeah among
buyers of B2B products and services more
than 90 percent consider content to be
worthwhile when they evaluate any
business
so we spent on average seven hours per
day consuming digital content and a lot
of this content is being consumed on
blogs did you know that there are over
500 million blogs on the internet and on
WordPress about 70 million blog posts
are published each month so these are
incredible numbers and we're going to be
talking about that yeah in this section
in this module we're going to be talking
about a very important part of content
marketing which is the actual creation
of content particularly when it comes to
writing right so let's get started what
are we going to be talking about in this
video we are going to be talking about
many things in the content marketing
industry did you know that content
writing is one of the fastest changing
areas of content marketing now you may
wonder what let me give you the answer
to this that is mainly because of
developments in artificial intelligence
if you use AI or artificial intelligence
tools you actually no longer have to
write the content you let those tools
write a content for you and the only
thing you will have to do is to edit the
end
um the output of the AI tool later I'm
going to share some AI tools with you
that you can be using for Content
writing but to understand these new
tools it is important that you
understand the basics of content writing
so in this video we will look at what is
content writing
why proper content writing is important
we'll look at the different types of
content that you can write for we'll
look at how to write proper content and
that is a skill in itself and I'm going
to close with right giving you some
content writing tips and in the process
of going through these uh topics I will
be sharing with you some interesting
content writing tools as well
so let's start at the beginning what is
content writing many people when they
think about content writing they think
about writing an article however writing
content isn't just in for a Blog yeah it
is for many many topics many other areas
that you can write for you can write for
many different areas you can write a
script for your video you can write for
your email newsletter you can write for
the pages of your website you maybe have
to write a keynote speech maybe for your
social media posts you have to write
titles for your podcast for your videos
maybe you're going to produce a white
paper that you need to write for or an
ebook landing pages are very important
content that you have to write for it
could be the descriptions for your
videos remember we talked about YouTube
SEO and we talked about how important
description of your video is and writing
for SEO purposes we talk talked about
that in other videos as well but it's in
another way writing is the foundation
for pretty much any content that you
publish
so what then is content writing content
writing as we say on the slide is the
process of planning writing and editing
web content typically for digital
marketing purposes
so we can include writing a blog post
and articles a script for your videos it
could be writing the show notes for your
podcast and it can also be content for
specific social media platforms the
thing they have in common you have to
write it before you can publish this and
that is where the challenges in content
writing you need to know how to write
and many people they don't think they
know how to write
well for those people who are afraid of
writing content rest issued after this
video you will be a lot less anxious to
get your pen or keyboard and put your
creative ideas on paper or on the screen
yes so that is what the basic essence of
content writing is now remember content
writing is not just for a blog post as I
mentioned earlier content writing
touches every aspect of your digital
marketing without good written content
your digital marketing strategy will
fail because it's the content that will
connect your readers with you and that
content that features everywhere in your
digital marketing and I can't emphasize
this enough I mentioned that before it
is on your blog post it's on your video
script it's in your email newsletters
it's in your podcast title it's in your
landing pages in your YouTube video
descriptions there's so many places
where your content will feature and you
can replicate a Content across those
different platforms so written once for
one medium doesn't mean you can't use it
on other medium so what is the golden of
content marketing the goal of good
writing of content writing is to connect
your readers with your business and in
such a way that you communicate your
message effectively and efficiently
and the better you're able to do this
the more likely the reader will engage
with you
so it's that engagement that turns into
trust and into loyalty so let me give
you an example you know the Michelin
tires in the early 1900s the Michelin
Brothers they started supplying
pneumatic tires to automobiles in France
now automobiles were mainly used in
Paris and of course the Michelin
Brothers they wanted to sell their tires
to more automobile users to more car
users across the country
cars were in that popular yet but they
wanted to give it a push so people would
take their cars to the countryside so
Michelin knew that to grow their
business to had to get they had to get
people to drive their cars outside Paris
and that's when the Michelin guide was
born yeah a book that contained the
rating systems for restaurants all over
France and also included information
about roads across France where to find
gas stations about hotels and of course
information about how to replace flat
tires or how to repair them and other
important facts about using a car so
this early example of content marketing
became a huge success and they were able
to build a global brand based on the
Michelin guide and the michelang guide
is still being used today so having
talked about this what is content
marketing why then is it so important
let's have a talk about that yeah the
essence of content marketing as I said
earlier is to guide the customer or your
prospects through their buying Journey
yeah and content writing is key to this
remember your content that you should
give to people or share with people when
they don't even know that they want to
where they want to go on a vacation for
instance is different than when they
have already made up their mind of going
on a beach vacation in uh in Barcelona
yeah if I don't know what vacation I
want I want to find content about what
are our holiday Beach holidays what our
city breaks what are Adventure holidays
yeah if I know what I want to do where I
want to go then I want to know
informative content I want to see
content about Barcelona about hotels in
Barcelona about what you can do during
Beach vacations yeah so it's very
important that your content drives your
customer or your prospect through that
buying Journey so you write content for
awareness purposes great content that
will go viral and reach as many people
as possible by creating well-informed
well-written well entertained and useful
content it will drive traffic to your
website and you will appear higher in
search engine rankings
next your content has to convey
information
yeah where you capture those in a
Content those people that have seen your
content you want to make sure that they
want to see more of your content yes so
you need to give them information that
will persuade them to take a certain
action I want to download an ebook or I
want to know more information about
something or want to sign up for a
newsletter or sign up for a webinar or
simply buy your product or service in
doing that you use your content to turn
awareness into interest which will lead
to more sales and will lead to referrals
it's a very simple and effective process
in marketing terms we call this inbound
marketing where you're going to reach as
many people as possible online who will
then if they're interested to come back
to you and engage with you
as opposed to outbound marketing where
you will go and get a list of telephone
numbers and your salesperson will call
everybody one at a time with a script
now that script needs to be written as
well in fact that is also content
writing yeah but inbound marketing is a
much more cost efficient way of
generating leads for this for businesses
these days so to summarize instead of
reaching out to individual prospects you
publish really good content that drives
traffic to your website which will lead
to more leads and ultimately will lead
to more sales so let's talk about the
types of content and the types of
content formats now when people think
about digital content they mostly think
about content for your website
which is the text they see on the web
pages now that's very important but
there's a lot more to that let me show
you an infographic that puts content
writing into a perspective
yep so that is different types of
content so here it will share the link
to this in the um in the description but
here you see the different types of
content that can be written for you have
technical writing you have press release
white writing report writing and
research writing
SEO content writing marketing and
communication writing instructional
design writing
CSR writing for social courses
editorial and publication writing
feature writing ghost writing is a form
of content writing as well where you
write for somebody else business writing
copywriting that is an interesting form
of writing yeah where you look at a
really competitive
creativity that you need to create get
to have very strong headlines for
instance so a lot of different types of
content that you can be writing for so
let's focus on the different types that
we can use particularly for marketing
yeah let me go back to the slides
yes so here is a summary of the
different types when it comes to
e-marketing we're looking at articles
yeah these are pieces that can be
published in a newspaper in a magazine
or in an online publication yep and that
is a very common type of content that
can be written for and that you will use
for your marketing purposes they can be
the traditional content like brochure or
product descriptions yes so a brochure
is like an advertising piece that
included template a booklet or a leaflet
and they have information about your
products about your services of course
as you differentiate Us and how people
can reach out to you
so that is an important part of content
as well then a very important part of
content is content for your website
yeah the pages on your website the
content in your website needs to be
written each page needs to be written
yeah they need to be written what you
see but also kind of needs to be written
what you don't see but what the search
engine
spiders will see and that's of course
when we talk about search engine
optimization very important you write
content for emails like email
newsletters
yeah or it could be just email campaigns
very important part you have your
headers or your titles of your emails
you have the description the summary of
your emails
press releases has been a long sort of
the type a very important part of
content that we've been written for many
many years yeah where in the early
pre-internet days press releases were
one of the most important documents to
reach out to journalists now press
releases are just another type of
content that you can share with your
your audience
and then finally ebooks is a very
important type of content ebooks were
also we called out lead magnets yeah
they are fantastic for adding to your
website where people when they're
interested can download them so that's
where the magnet comes in people are
interested they click on download to
ebook but before they download they have
to give them they have to enter their
email address and or their telephone
number so very important different types
of content that you can be focusing on
so here is the big question
can everybody write good content
yeah so a lot of people think oh no I'm
not good in writing so I need to get a
copywriter in now before I can answer
the question if everybody is good in
proper in content writing let's discuss
the difference between copywriting and
content writing often they will overlap
yeah and many writers they act as both a
copywriter and a Content writer but then
what there is a difference it's a very
subtle difference
copywriters usually focus on persuading
readers in selling a brand
it's often short form it appears on ads
on products on taglines and similar
types of marketing copy so it's short
it's punchy it's capturing the essence
in a couple of statements that's often
what we call copywriting content writing
is usually for longer form content
focusing on informing educating or
entertaining the readers it's content as
we said earlier that takes the reader
through their buying Journey so while
it's true that anyone can write it's not
enough to just put the words on a page
content writers and copywriters must
craft something compelling something
original something engaging and
ultimately something well written
and when you're able to do that of
course the quality we're able to do that
producing high quality content the
benefits are huge yeah it gives you
something to use across all your
marketing channels yeah so you can turn
a blog post into an Instagram post into
a Facebook post into a tweet into a blog
post on LinkedIn yeah so lots of
different things that you can do with a
good piece of content
good content really helps you with
search engine optimization
Google will reward you for having new
fresh content on your website by giving
you a higher search ranking good content
helps you establish your Authority in
your end your in your Niche or in your
industry thereby it helps you in
establishing your brand and also good
content will go viral it will go wide it
will reach many people and that means it
will reach potentially new customers
so very important to think about these
benefits that you will get from good
proper content writing
and as I said everybody can write
content but your challenge is to make
sure your copy your copy that you write
is compelling original engaging and
ultimately well written but as I
mentioned earlier there are many tools
now and particularly in the artificial
intelligence field that can help you in
to turn boring content into very
exciting content so let me give you some
tips on how to write exciting content or
as I like to call it killer content
the first thing you need to do is to
Define your target audience
yeah who are you writing for
do you understand their needs do you
understand their interests do you
understand their pains
yeah a an e-book for a marketing
director will be different than an ebook
for a finance director so you need to
know who you're writing for
in digital marketing terms we talk about
customer personas
yeah you need to Define to create your
customer personas and here is a tool
that I like to share with you it is a
tool from HubSpot make my personas in
HubSpot it talks about what is a Persona
what is a buyer Persona you can learn
about that but here you also see build
my Persona yeah so if you click on that
it takes you through a simple process in
a walk through mode where you can create
your own customer personas
you can also skip the walkthrough mode
and then here you see a typical Persona
the name job title age their level of
Education what social networks are they
using what is their preferred method of
communication what are their
responsibilities what are their goals
and objectives what are their pain
points their challenges you do this for
your most important customers so if
you're selling to marketing directors
this could be marketing Jill yeah or
Finance directors it could be Finance
Joe or Finance Mark or if you're talking
to women with children who buy shoes
yeah then it could be
um
Family Jane yeah so very important to
create customer personas once you've
created those customer personas you're
going to look at your next step it's
where you're going to choose a topic
when you choose a topic you find a topic
that you're going to write about that is
relevant for your audience and it aligns
with your business and your organization
goals a really good tool that you can
use here to write proper content is a
tool called Google trend
Google Trends yeah it helps you explore
what the world is searching for so let's
say I'm going to write an article about
remote working yeah then here I see the
trends I want the trends worldwide
and here I can see give me the trends
for the past let's say 2004 till present
and here I can see the trends in the
term remote working from 2004 to
2023. now these are the volumes of
people searching for the term remote
working and interesting that you can see
here as well how it develops and here
you see tape for instance this Spike
where did this Spike come from guess
what this was the start of covet yeah so
there was a search in people that had to
start working remotely and you see that
it gives findings you see that in the
results on Google Trends as well if this
trend would go down yeah so take for
instance a term like
a video recorder yep and we're going
back to Global worldwide and we're going
to do from 2004 till present yeah so you
see clearly very popular in the 2010
tens but you don't want to write about
video recorders today because it is a
dead topic
okay so that is the power of Google
search a very good tool to check the
topics that you want to write for are
they gaining are they popular are they
gaining in popularity or are they going
down in popularity once you've decided
on your topic you're going to do the
next thing and you're going to research
the topic yeah so you're going to gather
information about your topic from
reliable sources
yeah you're gonna check if there is
other people writing about the topic can
you learn from that can you get some
ideas from that so you can form your own
opinion before you start writing the
content a really good tool that you can
use for this
is a tool called bus shumo
in bus Sumo you can just analyze content
that has been published on the internet
yes so let's look at working or remote
working yeah when I'm gonna search for
that then bus Sumo is going to give me
an analysis of the most popular articles
on the internet at this moment about the
topic remote working here you see how
much engagement the topic gets how many
shares on Facebook how much engagement
on Reddit number of links and here you
see the total engagement of that article
yes so very good to research articles
because if this is a very popular
article then you may want to read the
article and get ideas from that article
okay so that is how you analyze content
the next thing you're going to do once
you've analyzed the content you are
Orion conducted a research you're going
to create an outline
yes so you're going to come up with
ideas you're going to look at the
structure of your content you're going
to look at the topics of your content
you're going to get some ideas about
titles for your content once you have
that outline like say five or six
bullets it helps you to stay focused and
make sure that your content flows
logically now when this is where
artificial intelligence comes in yeah
this is where you can use tools to help
you in creating that outline a really
good and easy tool to use here is a tool
called simplified.com
yeah in simplified.com it helps you to
write for AI purposes if I go home you
can see you can write content you can
write a YouTube script you can expand
sentences you can make them shorter and
there's a lot more that you can do you
can actually there's a full blog wizard
you can write a full blog post for you
yep but you can also just create a new
document let me show you I'm not going
to demo the whole product but here you
can see the flow that you will go
through so the first thing you want
block titles and ideas
yeah and there are templates that I can
pick for this yeah the topic is going to
be let's say uh remote working
yep and now I'm going to just click
generate and the tool is now going to
generate block titles for me yeah so
seven ways to make remote working a
success for you and your company the top
10 benefits of working remotely eight
steps for a successful remote working
setup the benefits of working remotely
Etc so let's take for instance
um so the top 10 benefits of working
remotely what I'm going to do I'm going
to add this to my article there we have
it number one yeah and if you look at
the topics here it can also create your
blog introduction the section completer
a conclusion prayer paragraph it can
even put it into the
um the customer buying Journey framework
so it is unbelievable what these type of
AIS AI tools can do for you another very
powerful a very simple product that I
often use is a tool called quill Bots
if I go to quill bot it's a paraphrasing
tool yeah and this is free you can use
standard and fluency for free you just
type in or paste the piece of text that
you want to rewrite and then you click
paraphrase yeah you can increase the
number of synonyms you can make it
fluent formal simple creative expand and
shorten the text a very simple but
powerful tool to paraphrase content so
watch this space yeah the artificial
intelligence is taking the digital
marketing World by storm okay
once you've got your outline written
you're then going to write a very
compelling headline writing the
compelling headline is probably one of
the most important parts of your
copywriting that people will remember
yeah so and that that headline must
summarize what the content is all about
but also it should grab people's
attention now there are many tools that
you can use to check your title yeah and
just search for tool to check title yeah
and then you will come up with a whole
selection of tools that you can use for
this also think about the paragraphs and
the bullet points it's very important to
break your content into short paragraphs
and to use bullet points to make it
easier for people to read and to scan
your article there's another reason why
short paragraphs and bullet points are
so important Google likes them and
particularly when it comes to
um to mobile search where Google needs
to place short content as answers to
queries that people have they prefer to
have bullets at content to actually use
for answering queries that people have
so finally there are a few more tips we
have subheadings subheadings are very
important and formatting is important
yeah headings are the first level of
your writing Masterpiece yeah so
headings is sort of the title of your
document they introduced a topic they
introduced a paragraph So The Heading
let the reader know where they are in
the document or the blog post they can
also include keywords yeah that relate
to the topic and again that's good for
your search optimization The Heading is
an essential part of the content that
you're writing because it tells the
reader what to expect from that piece of
text
subheadings are the second level of a
document they introduce a topic or a
paragraph
their function is to break up longer
sections into smaller more manageable
pieces
Singh gave it as a bullet point under
your heading so headings and subheadings
are the signposts of your content they
indicate the summary of a section
written under a heading or subheading so
it helps people to quickly understand
the section that is following and then
of course the formatting is important to
let pieces of content come out as well
like bold italics underlining using
different colors that can make your
content more visually appealing
right so now that we looked at how you
can write proper content yeah the mod
the final piece is of course to edit and
proofread and proofread and edit yes so
constant editing is very important you
may want to have multiple people
contributing to your document yeah so
very useful to ask your colleagues to
have a look at a document and maybe add
their comments add their ideas to the um
the content as well and then when your
final piece is ready make sure that
before you
publish it you proofread it for spelling
and grammar errors
yeah and that's where word processors
these days of course they all have
spelling Checkers so that's the minimum
you should do is to have a spelling
checker go through your document
now typos are very easy to miss when you
check it on your screen
so my advice is to print your document
yep and then read it on paper that will
give you a different view of your
document and you will see that you often
take out typos if it is a shorter
document a very powerful way to
proofread is to read it backwards yeah
because when you're reading it backwards
you're not thinking ahead of what the
sentence actually will be but you're
just analyzing each word by itself
good so that is all about writing proper
content let me close today's session
with some particular content writing
tips
first of all know your purpose we talked
about that make sure that you know what
you're writing you know who you're
writing it for do you want your content
to inform do you want it to convince do
you want it to entertain yeah so what is
your content going to be about and who
is it going to be for so know your
purpose
I always use a very simple acronym kiss
keep it simple
sometimes I keep I use case with two s's
keep it simple and stupid use Clear
concise language and avoid jargon or
technical terms that may be confusing to
your audience ask your mom to read it
because if she doesn't understand it
then maybe some of your customers may
not understand it it's very simple to
very important to keep it simple and
since you're so involved in your product
and services for you the technical terms
are day-to-day language for your readers
they are probably not day-to-day
language
use active voice yes so writing active
voice makes your content more engaging
yeah so it is you're not talking about
that day the people of our company
decided but you say that they we decided
yes so use terms like we like us in your
documents so use the active voice that
makes it much easier to engage with
use images and media of course text is
the core element of your content writing
but you can spice up your document with
images and media
or videos and other forms of media make
it visually appealing
people read but people will remember
what they see and people will remember
what they hear so yes your content
writing is important but spices up with
good video of good images and other
forms of media yeah now when you use
images or photos make sure that you're
using royalty free videos or photos or
that you pay royalties on the photos
that you want to use
there's no better photo images to use
than your own images yeah so use your
own photos do a photo shoot for your
products and create your own library of
photos if you want to use royalty-free
photos one of my favorite tools for that
is a tool called gratisography in karate
discography there's truly unique usually
Whimsy photos photos so they are
slightly different than the photos you
would get from the traditional photo
libraries
yep so be aware make sure that you use
quote or photos of the best content in
your um in your content that you're that
you're creating
use formatting to your advantage we
talked about formatting use headings
bullet points bowling color can make it
a lot easier to read so use that to your
advantage and then use the storytelling
technique now storytelling is a term
that has come into marketing about a
number of years ago particularly when
everybody started talking about content
marketing people are naturally drawn to
stories
yeah and there are lots of techniques
that you can use to create stories to
make your content more engaging and more
memorable
so storytelling is a concept that is now
adopted by most brands that are online
because again people will remember good
stories so let me give you my five C's
of Storytelling the first C is the Sea
of circumstance so when you create your
content write the circumstance write the
environment write the situation that
you're trying to describe to portray
the next C is to see for curiosity
people are curious so address this
curiosity feeling put questions make
people curious about the answers that
you're going to give them
yeah so curiosity is a very important
part of your storytelling the next C is
the Sea of characters people identify
with characters if you create a
character in your story use a character
whether it's a hero whether it's a
villain yeah then people will identify
with those characters and they often
remember those characters
those characters have conversations and
that is the fifth the fourth C of the
storytelling people have conversations
so let your characters tell stories have
conversations with other people
and then the final C is the Sea of
conflict and to me that is one of the
most powerful aspects of Storytelling it
is conflict every good story has a
conflict
good movies have a hero and have a
villain good movies have adversity and
have
good luck or have a world without the
adversity yes so it's conflict it is
um two sides of the of the coin yeah
it's positive it's negative it's here
it's there so create that conflict in
your story one of the companies that
uses con
um storytelling at its best is a company
called
Airbnb you may have booked
through Airbnb but Airbnb is fantastic
in storytelling so here is a section of
their website it's called Airbnb
experiences
Unforgettable activities hosted by
locals so this is where local people who
are having their Airbnb on the who are
having their house or their Chalet or
their condo on Airbnb where they share
their stories of things to do in the
environment that they um where they will
rent the house
so very powerful in content marketing
and in storytelling so have a look at
this it is really good
okay so that is the telling your story
as a very important part of your content
marketing
so the next thing you want to focus in
on is making sure that your content has
very strong calls to action when people
read your content make sure that they
have somewhere where they can click to
go to the next step
yeah that could be registering for a
newsletter
signing up for a webinar
or getting more information or
downloading an ebook
calls to action are vital in digital
marketing because in the end you want
your reader to become a customer
and then it goes without saying make
sure that you have a consistent tone and
style throughout your content so we call
this a house style so many Brands before
they start creating content they have a
document which summarizes their house
style their tone of voice their visual
identity the colors that they're using
the fonts they're using how you can use
the logo
Etc it's all about creating a cohesive
and professional image
and then there's two more tips that I
want to share with you before we wrap up
make sure that you keep your content up
to date yeah there's various reasons why
you want to do that to make sure that
your customers when they read your
content read the latest and the greatest
second it helps you to put new life in
your document if new things have
happened in your industry add it to your
document and republish it again so it
means it means that your document
remains relevant is accurate and Google
likes that as well and then finally
as part of your storytelling use
examples and use anecdotes use real life
examples to help illustrating your
points to make your content more
relatable and more engaging and that is
where storytelling comes in that's where
your conversations come in that's where
your characters come in and often
customers are very good characters to
talk about your products and can give
you examples in the content that you are
writing
and that is a wrap yeah that's all I
have to share with you about content
writing if you want to know more about
it then check other simply learned
courses on content marketing on social
media on digital marketing and of course
if you like the video don't forget to
click the like button and if you want to
subscribe to our Channel click the
Subscribe button below and that will
give you access to a whole wealth of
courses on our YouTube channel so thank
you very much and I will see you at our
next video take care
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here